c'est une foule très enthousiaste de guy
et s'est passé ici face au parlement de
québec pour assister le 13 ou 1974
s'ouvrait à québec la superfrancofête ce
festival international de la jeunesse
francophone d'une durée de 12 jours est
organisée dans un contexte favorable
alors que le français se trouve au coeur
de l'actualité
la loi sur la langue officielle vient
d'être adopté par l'assemblée nationale
le festival appartient aux jeunes le
présent ouvrage sur l'avenir le
spectacle d'ouverture intitulé j'ai vu
le loup le renard le lion attire une
marée humaine sur les plaines d'abraham
je te dans tous les sens mais heureux
qui étaient présents lors de cette
ouverture magistrale avec jean hieaux le
plat richard loi et je pense que ça m'a
marqué marc est vraiment c'est une
empreinte importante dans la tête des
gens j'imagine qu'il ya des cafés qu'il
fait des petits bien sûr avec des
représentants de 25 pays dont plusieurs
délégations africaines des spectacles
tous les soirs sur les plaines d'abraham
et des rendez-vous au pigeonnier et à
l'université laval la ville grouille de
monde
les volets tant culturel que sportif de
la superfrancofête rallye le public qui
élargit ses horizons au rythme de ses
découvertes
cette espèce de liberté de fraternité y
avait beaucoup de monde et des gens d'un
peu partout ça c'était merveilleux parce
que on découvrait aussi de la musique
d'ailleurs disons ça nous a menés vers
plus grand c'est bien mais vers quelque
chose de plus grand que jamais dos et
c'était d'ailleurs une semaine
moi j'étais
pour moi c'était une deuxième grande
fenêtre quelques ip couvrait sur le
monde extérieur savait comment 167 et
évidemment quelques années plus tard la
superfrancofête est venu donner une
autre marche cette quête du peuple je
peux m'exprimer comme ça yanick
villedieu est un membre du service
d'information de la société d'accueil de
la superfrancofête il se rappelle
enthousiasme témoigner par la presse
montréalaise dès les débuts de
l'événement alors que rien n'était
pourtant gagné d'avancé
disons que la presse de montréal était
pas très convaincu qu'on pouvait faire
quelque chose de grand en dehors qu'à
montréal
évidemment et quand l'événement a
commencé et un journaliste s'appelait
jean v dufresne qui est en gros de voir
à l'époque et qui a fait un article tout
à fait enthousiaste et ça comme
déclenché effectivement un respect ou un
engouement de la presse montréalaise
ça a été vécue comme un événement majeur
qui a été reconnu comme ça ne s'était
surtout la population on accourt n'a
enregistré que 1 million 200 mille
entrées sur les sites où on a mentionné
à plusieurs reprises au fil des ans un
événement inattendu et inespéré et
inégalée c'est vraiment toute la
communauté de la région qu'elle ait de
nombreux citoyens de québec ont
accueilli chez eux des participants
provenant de divers pays
il y avait un accueil extraordinaire
juste pauvre deschambault qui accueille
le mali parle donc il y avait une
découverte on accueillait le bon dans
l'accueil des gens aux yeux de plusieurs
le concept de spectacle événement est
née avec la superfrancofête chez nous à
québec qui avons inventé les grands
spectacles avec charlebois vigneault
leclerc le loup le renard et
[Musique]
je pense que ça a eu une influence au
festival d'été genre de tracé d'un poids
ici valérie cloutier radio canada québec